ma mère est soupçonnée
arrivent au collège ça sur la figure toi
et de la baston quoi elle ne posait pas
de question n'était pas très attentive
restait encore le scalène c'est pas bon
j'ai fait un bien fou
qu'est ce que vous faites là bijoux j'ai
raté le bus notamment vous n'allez pas
rester là à traîner comme ça tu veux
essayer marvin et ckoi d'improviser
vous avez un monde à une réponse est
c'est fait plus sérieux aurel à jour
n'était même pas foutu d'aller chercher
marvin et moins vivant craindra pas une
coupe des salles consacrées aux ruines
où flottent comme ça aussi avec les
manades [ __ ] je me suis sauvée pour
devenir quelqu'un d'autre
c'est à dire soi même
puisque vous êtes comme moi fait quelque
chose de pas de différence
[Musique]
et
avant rééducation isabelle huppert
bonjour vins vignes tu verras c'est un
garçon très intéressant mais j'en doute
pas
[Musique]
il est votre rapport avec le théâtre
seul en scène votre avis compte
énormément pour moi
nous on revient sa culture sound j'ai
connu moi
bon moi j'étais connais moi
si nos vitrines dans la môme est en
train de monter c'est pas plutôt l
inverse c'est pas plutôt vous qui avez
essayé de me tuer moi je vous aime comme
vous êtes
c'est parce qu'on est qui compte c'est
ce qui est au fond nous
[Musique]
avant les couilles à bourg face qu'à
d'affaires
[Musique]